this is carol kovalick of in air
carol inair is one of the largest
operators in poland now but certainly
western poland with a major slice of
ftth tell us a bit about the network
yeah uh
our ftth network is mostly a jeep
network we started the project in 2010
and even though we are original so far
we
were able to
attract 20 000 of our customers to join
our ftth network
when it comes to the the size of the
network it consists of around 68 000 hps
homes fast
uh so
if you look at the whole number which uh
ftdh council is reporting in poland
which is around 97 000 homes connected
to tth so we have around 20 of of that
that's great tell us what were some of
the hurdles you had to overcome to to
achieve that when you first set off on
this project
for us it was difficult to start with
the project uh because uh like we're all
we're a typical cable operator so we're
operating our uh docsis network using
coaxial cables and most of our most of
the vendors were trying to convince us
that we should follow that route that we
should upgrade to docsis 3.1 and the
next versions however we were seeing
this as a sort of a trade-off which may
protect our old investment however it's
not ultimate solution we see we see that
this sort of ftp h fth is the ultimate
solution but fttb or ftc are these
trade-offs where you just protect your
all the investment but you don't reach
the ultimate solution yet so that's why
we decided now there there is no
intermediate point for us we need to go
to the the final solutions and we did it
to just get rid of all the bottlenecks
which are involved in keeping the the
old cables twisted pair or coaxial
cables in place
and and you've got plans for even more i
think that's right uh our plan is to
double in the this year in fact we we
want to build
around 67 000 new hps which in that time
we hope to to fill with new customers
but the size of this network will double
before i let you go and carry on with
that installation final question just
tell us what's been some of the benefits
to your customers uh
typically like we are
a service provider so we provide
a high capacity service
using uh ftth network currently our
services are reaching uh half gigabit
per second
and the customer can use uh whatever
over the top services uh he wants
from our perspective we see a big
advantage in having a ftph because it
simplifies lots of the operations we
don't have any intermediate active
points we need to manage so all the
complexity which is involved in
maintaining high number of outdoor
active nodes
is removed with
passive optical networks
and
this
brings a higher quality
it's less
failure and
it simply
provides a seamless internet service for
our customers without much hassle from
our side that's really interesting thank
you very much for joining us thank you
pleasure to meet you
so we're seeing in western poland where
ftth networks is not only improving
network access but is easier for the
operator to run